what the hell was that so patreon
sponsored review time and this is one of
those cases where I got commissioned to
watch the first two episodes of a show
that I haven't seen before
that happened a little while back with
mr. robot which I was intrigued by no I
haven't watched more not because I
didn't think it looked good because my
time yeah I'd like until I'm in a
position where this is my my how I pay
my bills like yeah I I just don't really
have time for this stuff so but I've got
another one of those and in this case
it's the Oh a now how it's one of the
awkward things that can happen with
patreon sponsor reviews is if I can tell
either because of general tone or
context or no outright because they say
it what the person commissioning me is
hoping to get out of it like for example
the patron who who sponsored me
reviewing Titans wanted me to tear it
apart and then I ended up really liking
it so I can't remember if the person who
commissioned me for the Oh II thought I
was gonna like it if you did I hope I'm
not gonna break your heart too much now
that having been said I'm actually
really glad that I saw this because
trying to figure out why I hate it cuz I
do I hate it was actually a really
interesting exercise because on paper I
shouldn't like knowing the kinds of
stuff that I like and other shows that
I've enjoyed thinking on this and going
why do I hate this so much was actually
kind of an in light
experience for me a little bit but we'll
get into all that so the Oh a if you
don't know what it is if you haven't
seen any of it it is it is the latest go
at someone trying to build a sci-fi
esque story out of a mystery that of
like we don't know what's going on don't
you want to find out you know it's which
is a pretty old chestnut that and it is
littered with shows that didn't make it
past one season or that like how to
hastily wrapped up second season and
maybe this one is good maybe it got good
later but I'm gonna deflect that defense
of this thing right now which is that
nothing that I saw in these first two
episodes wouldn't make me want to stick
around to see if it got better later so
even if it does even if it got
significantly better after this it blew
the first impression so okay the when it
opens we have a young woman I mean I say
young woman I guess she's in her early
she's younger than I am so mine's a
young woman darn kids drove my lawn she
is she's taken into custody when she is
spotted attempting to jump off
well no not attempting she does jump off
a bridge and she does not die she
doesn't even flatline though she asks
whether or not she did and in the
process of them trying to find out who
she is it turns out that she is a woman
who went missing he was seven years
previously but the thing is when she
went missing she was blind but she can
see now and she is super vague about
everything and yet has this really odd
thing where she won't like we know she's
capable of lying because
we see her lie about stuff at a few
points but she's incapable apparently
and Dutton cannot think that there's a
better judge in y'all better judgment
when people ask what's your name or yo
are you prairie after your last name of
the woman who vanished was and she says
I'm the Oh a so there's our mystery who
is this woman where'd she come from why
can't she see what's the Oh ay why do I
care oh look I don't that's jumping
ahead a little bit though okay so in
terms of setting up something that is
mysterious that is not entirely clear
what's going on that is presumably gonna
answer a lot of stuff later as much as I
said that there are plenty of shows out
there you know that start with this and
just go nowhere because they they
whether they are well executed or not
they don't pick up the the following is
basically a heck of a lot of shows
trying to chase lost in a lot of ways
most of these things feel like and it's
arguable how well lost even managed to
maintain itself though at least it got
multiple seasons out of it
the thing is there are shows that I can
think of that are strange right out the
gate that I don't know what's going on
and I am presuming that later on I will
understand it better that I enjoyed
quite a bit like some examples like I I
don't know if I've mentioned this before
I've only ever seen the first season of
Lost but I really liked the first season
of Lost I really like Legion which kind
of has a similar you know general vibe
going on you know it opens just weird as
heck so like I can't enjoy this I mean
heck even Doctor Who like at this point
it's second nature to me but you know
that that first episode wise well either
one you know the very first episode and
on earthly child which barely explains
anything or even Rose explains very
little you know so this can
work for me but it doesn't here and I
think the major reason why it doesn't is
I had nothing to cling to so like with
those examples that I gave and all the
ones that I could think of where I have
enjoyed them there was something that I
could relate to wrap my head around and
just kind of grab on to and go okay this
is my stabilizing element while I try
and navigate all the weirdness you know
it's like you're in a you're in this
gale force wind of nonsense but you know
this is this is the stable metal bar in
concrete you can grab onto okay I'm not
gonna get swept away I can stabilize
here and figure this out that metaphor
probably makes no sense but that's where
my brain went but in any case so like
with lost as much as that was so was
weird right off the bat plane crash on
an island need passengers needs to
survive that's a stabilizing solid thing
for me to start with you know Doctor Who
started with ROS average normal girl and
and even the doctor you know and
explained kind of a bit about his deal
fairly early on but you know a couple of
things like cool this dynamic I get it
and even something like Legion I would
say in the very first episode I kind of
latched on to Aubrey Plaza's character
but that that was the thing he kind of
hooked me on one or two characters as it
went along so I can go whoo I feel like
I I got you there's like all these other
people like don't know what's going on
but I get you so I can start there and
then I got stable enough where even as
the show got weird or especially around
her character I still felt okay because
I had that initial thing that I could
hold on to there's nothing for me to
hold on to in the OI it doesn't do a
very good job of establishing how
realistic the world is that this is
meant to be taking place in what I mean
by that is again to make the comparison
to say Legion lead
gives you the vibe very early on that
the it's not just the characters in the
situation that change the world is
strange the world has a surreal feeling
to it so that loosens up my willful
suspension of disbelief because I know
that wherever whatever we're dealing
with the baseline is not standard
reality with this it feels like it's
supposed to be realistic but nobody acts
like a person nobody speaks
nobody talks the way a human would talk
and most people don't act or react the
way that like people as I understand
them would behave and it doesn't
establish its world in its setting as
stylized enough for me to roll with that
as an artistic choice it just feels like
it's written by Sun but it's written by
a machine that doesn't really understand
people feels like it's written by an
algorithm half the time and the like
these characters I either have no reason
to invest in or the one that they sink
the most time into like to get me to
understand who he is I and that will be
Steve now I'm pretty sure I'm supposed
to hate Steve but if that's the case I'd
say they did the job - well because I
hate him so much that my gut reaction is
to the idea that this show redeems him
is to tell the show to go to hell like
no and like that could very well again
be part of the message of the thing
later on like this sort of maybe
justifying why he deserves Redemption if
it even goes that way I have no idea but
I can tell you I hated him and I hated
that the titular character was latching
on to him like he was gonna be her
lifeline I was just thinking like no no
no no no
not this not this guy please I really
there was something about okay I guess
somewhat spoilers now I mean I'm only
you're talking the first two episodes so
take it as you will but when you've got
a teenager and like I understand he's a
kid and kids do stupid stuff but I'm not
necessarily saying somebody should be
condemned forever for something that as
a kid he punches somebody in the throat
he coulda killed him and he didn't care
and he had no reason to do it besides in
that instant he was frustrated because
of something that had nothing to do with
this kid in the first place and then the
show has VOA I want to call her the BS
but I'm resisting the Oh way goes like
pretends to be his stepmother and goes
to this parent-teacher conference and
talks the teacher out of pushing to have
him removed from the school no like I'm
not saying that there's no path for for
this kid but you remove somebody who
punch someone in the friggin throat from
that school and how dare you you friggin
pretentious show frame this like it's a
good thing that he's still there fight
me what not how and like pretentious is
a good word for this thing to the point
at which I snapped and the first episode
is about an hour twenty minutes second
one's about an hour and I guess that's a
standard length after that so the
episode just kind of goes for a while
and it's nearly an hour in when the
credits roll a Netflix presentation
shows up and that was the point at which
I started swearing loudly at the TV
because that
was like the that's one of the most head
stuck up its own ass things that I've
seen a TV show do in a long freakin time
and then it moves along with the Oh a
giving her own life story of her
childhood and how she went blind and
sort of a situation that she ends up in
at the end of the second episode or at
least in the flashback it happens at the
end of the second episode so obviously
this is in her own past and that worked
better for me than the first episode and
I found myself thinking I might be able
to get into this story like it's the
story she's telling not the framing
device like I do not care but I might be
able to get into the story she's telling
if it was prevent if it was presented
straight if that was just being told to
me as opposed to this ridiculous framing
device that is all these elements that I
hate and which include that kid include
the fact that she calls herself the Oh
way I'm like what what and like most of
the worst dialogue is in the the
modern-day setting in the quote-unquote
real world so like when it's her telling
a story of her own childhood I can go
with the more still to stuff a bit
better because it's framed as a
narrative so I can allow for that
license a little bit better and you need
to realize what Sakurai I should be for
this because I've mentioned this before
I am such a sucker for stories about
stories and the power of storytelling
and it looks like he's trying to go for
somebody that but I still hate it so it
like it teed up to take a whack at
something that I almost always have a
soft spot for no just God no this thing
like about the one and only thing that I
was kind of like oh and this isn't
necessarily a priest for the show it's a
praise for the cast I mean from a
writing perspective because most of what
I'm complaining about is writing I am a
really amazing performances performances
are fine they're fine like I said the
the the they don't people on speak like
human
beings but that's a righty but the
problem is the writing the problem is
the scripts
I hate these scripts but the other thing
that I mentioned cuz I wouldn't be so
you know given my own you know gender
standing I wouldn't be surprised if this
was an aspect or an element for why was
suggested to me there is a young trans
male character played by a young trans
male actor which is cool and I like that
however this is one of a handful of
characters that at least in the two
episodes that I saw we basically get no
proper introduction to and is just kind
of they're the ones we spend a lot of
time with our VOA Steve then a bit of
time with Steve's teacher and like
there's a couple of other characters
there's this young trans boy there's
like Steve's I don't know if he's
actually his friend but he's like kind
of his Lackey
I suppose Steve's a bully like
monstrously so and like if I didn't make
it clear up to this point like screw
this kid seriously yeah I didn't uh I
didn't like it I really I should I
should have kept a tally for how many
times I I shouted at the TV some variant
of what is this what am i watching why
any of it like I it felt like it came in
and just assumed that being mysterious
would be enough of a hook in and of
itself but it's not it's not hard to be
mysterious it's actually damn easy to be
mysterious you present something and go
and explain what the heck it is that's
not hard what's hard is getting us
invested in the mystery by getting us
invested in the characters or at the
very least giving us some stabilizing
something so that we we know where we
stand with some element as we try and
grab our heads and judge this weirdness
and this thing fails to do either one of
those I oh man and like I said
maybe it gets better later I've got a
co-worker who's been pestering me to see
this show for ages and you know I I told
him you know why boy might have been a
little mean I was I think I went into
his offices and what what did I do to
you that you'd recommend this show to me
but yeah I just nothing about what I saw
in these first two episodes would make
me ever want to keep going so like I
said at the beginning even if it gets
better as far as I'm concerned it
doesn't matter cuz it blew the initial
impression so badly and rubbed me the
wrong way so hard so that's the Oh a
first two episodes I have a distinct
feeling I'm gonna tick off a lot of
people would this seems to be a really
well-regarded show from the people
who've seen it this is probably a
minority opinion I'm not trying to take
anybody off I'm not trying to troll I
just really hated it but have you seen
the oh way or at least the first two
episodes of it if you have drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it whole bunch of something
you can do because there's buttons and
links there's merch there's patreon it's
a huge help and as I mentioned this very
episode of this this very video is
sponsored through a patreon commission
but click on stuff down below it'll take
you to those places check it out or
don't you don't have to because assuming
that I didn't piss you off with this
review at the end of the day you are
also the council and me I'm just running
the meetings so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]